to be able to make sure that everything
is lined up before we are here
um and start presenting
um I do have this piece of paper here
from representative Merchant so I'd like
to recognize him to speak thank you
madam chair
last time we talked about three issues
that we tried to address we'd like to
address in the bill
one was the issue of who gets to use the
the data and we want to be sure it was
restricted to a clinical care of the
patient
two we talked about the issue of consent
which is in lines two sorry 12 to 13 and
14.
and lastly which is the thicket one is
the issue about de-identified patient
data and where it goes for
clinical research and clinical or
genetic analysis which is lines 15 16-17
so I proposed to the subcommittee
this as a draft against only a working
graph that hasn't been sent to OLS for
drafting but I wanted to start with this
as a place to have a conversations
so I guess my first question is just to
make sure that um that by having it in
this section does this take away from
the constraints we have on clinical
laboratories
um because I do know that there are the
other sections that speak to use the
genetic testing in other situations and
so I want to make sure that we don't
dilute what we're doing about clinical
laboratories in an effort to solve this
problem which in which may or may not be
the exact right section of the statue
each of these
um
paragraphs refer to this section so
whatever we say here when we go for our
section
yes thank you I just want to make sure
that we're not taking away from what
what we're doing with the clinical
laboratories by having it in the Statue
too
so
as I review this I'm going to take an
eye to that did you want to speak
representative
um I think this is helpful I guess one
thank you
I think this is helpful and I really
like the language on the first three
paragraphs so all of line from 3 to 14
um and and it now does flow
from
what's already in the statute but
um
I think the thing that we're going to
get hung up on once again is the use of
the identified data that's in the last
paragraph so
um
I'm I'm still trying to come up with a
formulation that I'm comfortable with
that's uh because what we're saying here
is on lines three to seven we're making
it very clear that the patient can
consent
for the purposes of of diagnosis and
treatment
and
8 through 11 also refers to entities
participating in clinical care
um
and then we again say
we're not waiving the requirement that
the treating position physician obtains
specific informed patient consent
I've I've looked at several formulations
for 15 through 17.
and
I'm not sure we've gotten there yet on
figuring out how to provide access to
de-identified data
and I I will also say that
with respect to de-identified data I
also have a proposed I think it was sent
to everybody a proposed definition from
The Honorable Neil Kirk that
as far as I can tell would de-identify
data so much that it wouldn't be useful
for research
because it de-identifies every single
solitary
characteristic that you would want to
know about
stuff but I'm I'm willing to be
persuaded and and once the subcommittee
is disgusting I I would ask that we
could hear from the folks who've come to
watch us fumble with this watch a
struggle with difficult tasks I have
similar I have a similar view of this I
think lines 3 through 14
um look good my one question would be if
um
if um it's necessary to still include
the evaluating potential clinical care
options within that language because I
do want to make sure that the third
party used in order to make sure that
patients are are evaluated and offered
as many clinical trial options as
possible is not limited by the language
that we have I don't think it is but I
just wanted to raise that concern
because that's one of the very important
parts of this legislation I I have a
very very large problem with this
de-identified patient data and
especially when you're looking to
retroactively open up access to people's
medical records when they may or may not
have consented I I don't know if there's
some way to add an additional consent
for somebody to blanket consent for a
de-identified data in the future for
clinical research and while that may not
give us the same access to historical
data at least we could start now having
people consent for their information to
be used on used in future research so
that they can open this up should they
choose to do that some people donate
their bodies to science if people are
willing to to donate their genetic
information and and more of their
medical record to science I think we
should enable that but I don't think
that we should do that for people
without specific consent although I'm
not sure exactly how to put that into
language
representative Merchant I totally agree
with both my colleagues on the
subcommittee it's um trying to thread
the needle here
with how to protect the patient in the
confidentiality that goes particularly
with DNA and genetic information however
try to Foster and support clinical
research which is really necessary in
the backbone of what we do to Foster
better care
I don't know exactly how to word it we
could possibly talk about the issue of
when the patient consents to providing
the data
so it's part of the consent form so
basically at that point in time is when
the patient can sense the release of
de-identified data
that could be another way to maybe word
it
thank you are you thinking of including
that within the whole consent or having
that as a separate additional level of
consent
how long do we want the form
um I hear you
I think it needs to be clear in the
consent form that when the patient is
consenting they understand what they're
consenting to so I think at that point
in time is that it probably should be
part of the Forum but I get nervous
about trying to then incorporate this
into the consent form because then we
have to think about
possibly incorporating other things into
the consent form I'm trying to avoid
thank you that does bring up the sticky
situation I
um I know some people may be fine to be
involved in current clinical research
but may not want to be looked back and
said you know you're a gun owner do you
have a different cancer profile and are
you going to bring that in together and
I'm worried about limiting people who
are participating in current clinical
research because they're worried about
what future clinical research they may
be included in either shortly in the
future or even after their death
and and
I don't want any chilling effects on
people that will be contributing to
research so I just want to figure out
how not to make the form too long I
think the Safeguard here as long as it
does remain de-identified
you are in essence but we are
collectively
protecting a certain level of
confidentiality on behalf of the patient
when you get into identifiable
information I get really really nervous
but if it's de-identified we provide to
the
public a lot of de-identified
information from many sources
um in the aggregate or maybe we should
which then also brings the problem of
rare diseases and I guess as we look at
it as a possibility of gun owners and
their exposure to let the question would
be then um if somebody if we were
looking at ovarian cancer and somebody
who had undergone an abortion to to make
sure that we're protecting people
throughout all of the spectrum's
information from potentially potentially
useful but also more personal
um personal leaning research
true
I would if it's deodemified it's hard to
trace it back to a particular individual
and that's why we de-identify it
so at that level even though I'm a gun
owner and so forth it'd be hard for me
to at that point in time determine
who's a gun owner who's not a gun owner
because there's no way to identify the
patient and Link it back to their
behavior or their
representative Weber
now I'm back to first of all wondering
what the folks out there think about
this because they're going to have to
live with it and and second for myself
um
I mean the more I the more I read all of
this the more I come around to this
thought that
uh
the statute is it now stands is really
quite clear to me
and
I'm wondering if we're muddying the
waters more than we're clarifying them
the bill originated
as
some I I I do understand that it
clarifies using
um
data data rather than specimens
um so in that respect it's a good thing
but
um I'm I'm I'm more comfortable with the
beginnings part with the stuff up
through line 14 than I am for 15 through
17. and I wonder if that isn't the
subject of a different piece of
legislation
or
you know as As Time ticks on I think
about retention
but I'd love to help out with the first
part
if we can do that
I I would agree that through line 14 I'd
be comfortable moving forward
um if 15 through 17 needed to be part of
it I also would lean towards retention
but there's people that may not live to
see January that I want to make sure
have access to clinical trials right so
I would rather
um rather separate off that 15 to 17.
I I would like to invite both of you up
if you'd like to share any insight that
seems to be the way that we're leaning
and if there's anything to convince us
of something that um where we would be
causing a problem by deferring the
de-identified patient data for a later
bill I would definitely like to know if
the language works and if that that
so thank you thank you for continuing to
address this I really appreciate your
your working through it
um and uh one through 14 going through
will be a big step forward so I will
appreciate that moving forward the
um as far as the de-identified data goes
uh representative Weber I think you
referred to what former representative
Kirk can put forward
the standard of de-identification that
actually very very closely parallels
what the the federal standard is for
de-identification
so that is not uh while that is limiting
the the point of that de-identification
is that de-identified data
cannot be traced back to any particular
individual
um so it still allows for a lot of
research there right so we can talk
about the the
care pathway that an unknown individual
went through we can talk about the
results that an unknown individual
obtained by certain treatments and
things like that while certainly a
limited data set which is to say that it
includes any of those identifiers that
doctor or sorry represent former
representative Kirk had pointed out if
any if it transgresses any one of those
right we need to know any of those 18
unique identifiers then we would refer
to as a limited data set it doesn't mean
that that includes the person's name but
um so so even though it's talking about
de-identified is to say that all of
those identifiers have been stripped out
and then we will consider kind of what
we know about an an unnamed unknown
person so that allows us to do a lot of
of research without any identities being
used there the
um
so continuing with that HHS standard
would be a big help for us to to do
research
um
uh with all of the strictness of that
that standard
the the last one you know the section
allows for the disclosure of the
identified patient data is a little bit
of a confusing statement to me because
I'm not sure exactly whom is disclosing
to whom in the and so that I I think
what I'm looking for is just the use of
de-identified data that's data related
to a to unknown persons may be used
within the covered energy covered entity
for
I would say research oh
within the cupboard any necessary to
conduct clinical research or genetic
analysis neither of those would actually
be true on the identified data right we
we wouldn't do clinical reasons we're
not doing anything to a specific person
obviously you're going to do it to the
person you need to know who they are so
we're not going to do clinical research
because um uh you you said something
about within the covered entity and that
already
makes me a little more happy because
it's not going outside the cover entity
uh whereas when we when we got this to
begin with it really read like it could
go anywhere so if you have
within the covered entity language I'd
love to hear it and if we could maybe
combine that if if we use limits are
okay for you
um I wonder if limiting to the use
within the covered entity which I assume
in this case in your case would be dark
and medical is that right the covered
entity would be would be Dartmouth
Health Dartmouth Hitchcock it would
actually exclude the college uh from our
by then okay
[Music]
is covered entity defined somewhere in
the
yeah Comfort entity is defined under uh
the health insurance portability uh
HIPAA as it's well known and the only
other thing I might add is uh former
representative kirkenheit communicated
about the language with respect to the
definition of de-identified data and
while
my suggestion would be to just
incorporate by reference to the federal
guidelines he clearly would prefer to
spell out each of the 18 or so criteria
plus and and we are not
objecting to that articulation if that's
de-identified data may be used
for
clinical
research I would actually sorry if I may
interrupt retrospective research might
just for research or just research would
be helpful but but to be clear you you
couldn't use the identified data for
clinical research so we'd be creating a
I put in retrospective so we know that
that's
that if we said solely within the
covered entity
representative Merchant I'm just looking
at
the definition here that I found through
NIH
and it's broader than I assumed I
thought of a covered entity being dark
with Hitchcock health or Dartmouth
health
but according to the definition here
because you're about the issue with
HIPAA which I don't I just I
makes me nervous when you talk about hip
and
people within HIPAA that consider
covered entities
it does include Health Plans Health Care
clearinghouses Health Care Providers
electronic transmit information to the
uh connections and so forth so it's
broader than what it
includes cover that is as defined by
HIPAA
health plans
Healthcare clearinghouses health care
providers who electronically transplant
any health information in connection
with transactions which HHS has adopted
standards so it basically comes down to
is what I call before which I've sort of
objected to is a business associate
is that definition one that is saying
any of these things can be a covered
entity or is that definition saying all
of these things are included within the
covered entity because it sounds to me
like they are saying these are the
things which could be could each
individually be a covered entity not
collectively
my read on this right now I'll let
somebody else look it over
means the second it's inclusive it
includes everything it's not separate
what's another way of saying HIPAA
business associate
and I would agree that without further
limitations on it no matter how we read
it that's likely how it would be
interpreted by people in the future and
that language also is not is it is too
broad for me
is there a another term that would cover
your uses between Dartmouth health and
to allow postdocs to actually do some of
this research
although I'm also wary about crafting
laws specific for entities so that
I I don't know if individual institution
works better for you I I will say
on the ground to someone that governs
the data we would consider sort of
represented whatever your your
the former interpretation to be how we
understand it that the covered entity
does not include those that each of
those could be a covered entity we would
never consider those as part of our
cover and covered entity I I can't
comment to how the whole world might
understand that but we've always
understood at the in the former sense
that those
are
those are covered entities they're not
us but they are themselves covered
entities
um but if individual institution would
I I think what we're looking for is just
to work within our own house we're not
looking to share it outside of that and
whatever language feels best to do that
that's what we're looking for we're not
trying for
and and run around that in order to move
it outside of the institution and that
was where I thought this would sort of
lock it down by saying covered entity
um but when I go back and look at the
definition it's a little broader than I
person thought
could you give me the side of stimulio
yeah
right but that that to me reads it says
covered identifies are defined in the
HIPAA
rules as health plans Health Care
Clearing Houses but those are each each
of those things is an individual covered
entity it's not in the aggregate
I look at it the other way it looks like
it's in the aggregate not in the
individual
so we'd say a covered entity it gets
back into the HIPAA business associate
which I'm trying to get to
and my question would be within a
covered entity versus within the covered
entity
because if it's the governance state
that received the consent that would be
more limiting than a
um can I zoom back out a little bit and
get a better understanding about what
kind of retrospective research you're
looking to do so I can understand what
the end goal is so we can figure out the
best way to meet this sure and and this
is a little bit of where the community
this prospective consent for future use
of data would get a little bit
complicated right because it's hard to
anticipate
everywhere that someone might want to do
research right so for instance right now
we would have data on breast cancer
patients that included some genomic
information that then a gynoc doctor who
wants to research ovarian cancers might
be looking to that data that we have
within our medical record but hadn't
been their patient at any point so
that's where we would want to use
de-identified no way to link it to an
actual a specific person
to use information that we had in order
to better understand this disease this
new disease process that's been
identified
so the prospective consent to that
becomes a little bit tricky because it's
hard to know what other researchers
might eventually have you know
meaningful ideas to investigate
so with that you're even talking about
matching controls for somebody else
within the system to have somebody with
a similar genetic makeup to see what
their course was or no or or
specifically so of the patients who had
a specific subtype of ovarian cancer how
many of them were positive for this Gene
that we were already testing for a
different cancer
again we're there's no clinical research
it's strictly retrospective so there
would we're not talking about matching
cohorts in a prospective study it would
only be used in retrospective analysis
is going to clarify the covered entities
are separate but they're linked to the
business associate agreement but but
they've got a definition here of covered
entities and business associates
and what it says about business
associates is if a current and covered
entity engages a business associate to
help it carry out its Health Care
activities and functions the covered
entity must have a written business
associate contract or other arrangement
with the associate that establishes
specifically what that associate has
been engaged to do and requires the
business associate to require with the
rules requirement to protect the privacy
and security of the health information
so if we
talked about a covered entity and its
business associate and lifted that chunk
of requirement of a written
contract about what the business
associate is doing
would that be a way of limiting the use
of de-identified data that would on the
one hand make it
still useful to you and and
but limited enough in scope that we're
not announcing it to the entire world it
that would be fine to be honest I think
that's even broader than what I'm
looking for so I would really be fine
with cover densities and excludes their
business associates well I'm I'm fine
we're not engaging other systems there
there's we don't need business
associates in doing our research the way
that we need them to do our clinical
care would we on line 16 says within a
covered entity change the
within a to within the yeah well what I
what I would propose is to start again
with a new sentence and say
um
de-identified data may be used for
retrospective research within the
covered entity period
and then say and then use representative
Kirk's list
de-identify I would change it a bit and
say de-identified data is data from
which the following information
has been removed and then do the list
would that get us
to a place we're all comfortable with
um I think that moves us closer when we
look at the covered entity I'm saying
it's a healthcare provider a health plan
or a healthcare Clearinghouse my
question would be if narrowing it to a
health care provider and a academic or
an academic research institution would
get us closer to the idea of being able
to have this information and then work
with those because if you're doing
research you're either in a clinic doing
research or you're an academic
institution and we definitely shouldn't
the NRL you could be in the commercial
industry and be working within Pharma
but I don't think that this should be
opened up to them
so if we were to have the health care
provider or an academic research
institution would that Cut the Cake cut
the slices a little bit narrower and
better to find where we're trying to
make sure that the information can be
used or am I uh in left field I'm I'm
working on this healthcare provider or
the second one was a
academic research Institution
or am I going too far okay so and I'm
limiting this in my sentence to the
covered identity a covered identity
which is a health care provider or
academic research Institution
may use de-identified
may use de-identified data
can I just can I ask a question of the
community because I don't have the
language in front of me of what they
enumerate as a covered entity could you
could you
share that well the the
you know I'm just trying to remember
there were a lot of different covered
identity that we were concerned about
but what I am writing here is a covered
entity which is a health care provider
or academic research Institution
okay Alexa
this talks about different types
of energy to understand reading this
they're really separate tenant the only
but I think it does this healthcare
provider as the First Healthcare first
type of Relativity right so when I what
I now have is a covered identity a
covered entity which is a health care
provider or academic research
institution may use de-identified data
to construct conduct retrospective
research
and then the next sentence is
de-identified data is data from which
the following information has been
removed and then we put in the laundry
list
I'm liking the direction of this I'm
wondering if the de-identified data
should live in 141 H colon to a just
separate because this is getting a
little bit more complex with those
definitions or if we just keep adding it
in here well like the section I mean you
you break the section down into
subsections okay
um but I think
I I don't want to have this definition
again migrate over
into any any other anywhere else and so
it should probably say for purposes of
clear about again health care provider
we're trying to lock it down to the one
it actually is collecting and using the
data because a healthcare provider
include anyone who's in health care
so therefore you have different types of
covered entities within the term
healthcare provider so I think
representative Weber could be going
because it really locks it down to the
academic Medical Center that the
institution that's actually collecting
foreign
it's not my my Ultimate Dream for
research but it is a big step forward
and I appreciate all of this
and this would all come after signing
the consent so this would not be
reaching back into anybody who has not
we have to be clear about that though as
well okay well I I suppose this is the
situation where we're talking about when
the de-identified data is when we can't
obtain consent
so this would be changing the terms on
which people collected their had their
genetic testing done previously no no no
no no
um so this is only on data so it's not
on specimens so we would not be going
back and performing
tests on specimens that we had
previously collected and there is
consent at the time of testing in order
to have genetic testing done but the use
of the data the the point of using
de-identified data is because we're in
situations where we cannot obtain
consent from individuals
so what did they consent to when they
gave their genetic information
well typically they're in reality on the
ground they're consenting to the test
itself so even if you're seen in the
cancer center at the time that you would
come to collect genomic data you would
have an appointment in the genetics
Clinic where you would be have your
consent would be specifically your
appointment your care your consent would
all be to have those genetic tests done
and talk about the implications for your
for your health
so people would have consented to their
genetic testing at that time in their
clinical care we would not obtain
genetic tests on anyone that had not
consented to it would somebody be able
to have the genetic test without
consenting for their data to be used in
research
well
right yes I I don't know that in every
situation where someone has come in and
gotten care and had a genetic test done
that they specifically consented to
research on their data
but I guess looking forward are you
saying that all of this would be wrapped
in that in order to have the genetic
testing you would also consent to your
data being used or would that be a
separate consent so you can have the
testing done you can choose to have your
information used to look for options for
you but you can say no I don't want my
data used for anybody else would that be
possible or would that not be possible
with what you are looking at
sorry let me go ahead and answer the
question the way the way I interpret the
way that I interpret the question is
answered in
uh the previous sections so you're
getting you're getting consent for care
and testing and then you're getting
consent to participating clinical
research you certainly don't have to
consent to participate in clinical
research
so we are putting these as separate
check boxes on the consent form we're at
specific authorization
that's why I believe we're headed okay
that's what I would like to see in this
because if you're withholding with if
you're withholding a service conditional
on your consent for other options that's
not really consent
and and the way I'm reading it is the
way
um Mr hood is reading it uh we have the
lines 12 13 14 and says which is very
strong language it says nothing in this
section shall be construed to waive the
requirement that the treating physician
obtains specific informed patient
consent in accordance with provisions of
this section for clinical research so we
said first you got to get the consent
and then a covered entity which is a
health care provider
may use de-identified data
for these purposes
I concur with that if I look at three
through seven
that's providing consent for treatment
right that's for myself
if I look through lines 12-14 I'm giving
consent to use the information in
clinical research right and they're two
separate things
for although clinical research involves
the patient right so so you're you're in
a you're enrolled in a protocol or
you're enrolled in a clinical trial so
clinical research which those things are
followed to find out if that protocol is
working in fact clinical trial is
working certainly every patient that
participates in that has very explicit
consent but it's actually much more
extensive and much more explicit than
just a consent to care
um
so for clinical research there's a yes a
lengthy explicit
Insight so how about if we then revise
this piece that we're still working on
is
um
foreign
is to put a specific consent requirement
on the use of de-identified data as well
but that gets you
nowhere is that what I'm seeing from
that really gets us nowhere
uh it gets you the future it loses the
whole past but that whole past is not
accessible at this point correct
it was the only thing sorry
um Dr moral can answer this question in
a better clinical sense but the the
whole purpose of the de-identification
is so that you you can't identify who
the the information comes from because
you strip away all those 18 plus things
that's the only way that you look at the
past
so this is basically built off of
somebody's medical record who owns the
medical record the patient or the
provider the patient owns the medical
record
so I guess to me I I'd be happy to
provide this information going forward
but um I don't like changing the terms
under which people received care and
received testing in the past so to me
that would be a major sticking point
um I do know that I did look and I saw
our emerging medical Technologies
commission did also pass the Senate
unamended so that may this may be a
better discussion for that committee
because that's speaking to emerging
medical medical Technologies and
emerging medical research so being able
to facilitate this retrospective look on
data I believe what would dovetail very
but I'm interested in how the rest of
the committee feels on the idea of
allowing a look back to people who did
not specifically consent to this versus
I'm inclined to suggest we draft up two
amendments and submit them to the
committee
one that um leaves retrospective data
separate and one which discusses I I
would draft two amendments one of which
is sections one to fourteen
which we are all quite in agreement with
um and then a second one that has
and I think the way I would phrase it
just to make it clear that we are doing
something different is in addition a
covered entity which is a health care
provider
may use the de-identified data to
construct
conduct retrospective research so people
really know what they're voting on and
de-identified data means this and then
we can just go on having this discussion
endlessly in committee but it
it provides us it provides us the option
for at least doing part of it and having
the discussion about the rest of it
that helps I guess um I I did want to
ask you if you know what the standards
are for the international Council on
harmonization for research if they allow
this look back on data or not because I
know that that there's a big issue
around reaching back into people's data
without specific consent
I'm not familiar with her
with their position okay
that's I I personally have no problem
going forward and being being future
looking so maybe it may be a matter of
three amendments to look at as well
representative Merchant I'm sorry I'm
not understanding what the third one
would be one that only allows the
research on retrospective um
de-identified data if they consent to
that because I could see somebody
consenting to current clinical research
but not wanting to be opened up for all
future data mining right representative
kind of words method this section allows
for the disclosure a de-identified
patient data with a consent of the
patient so therefore if you get consent
from the patient you can go back as far
as you want because they're providing
you that consent
it's it's it's
clumsy but it's one of those things at
least you're getting consent from the
patient if you only want to do it going
forward you'd have to do that every
single time but if you want to go back
retroactively you'd have to get the
patient's consent to do that number two
such data shall remain within the
covered entity that collected the data
as necessary to conduct clinical
research or genetic analysis so it's
very clear stays within the covered
entity they collected it
thank you
if I made so I
I I understand your concern but I I
think that there's a
um a split the the use of a
de-identified data is specifically used
in the situation where you can't get
consent so to add this element of you
must use consent you must obtain consent
to use the identified data the role of
de-identified data in research is in
these unconsensable situations so I
I I feel like we're creating a new
constraint that doesn't really
understand that the on the ground the
reason that we're using that in the
first place right that if we're going
and attaining consent then we would look
for limited data sets or identify data
or things that were more expansive
because people had including themselves
we we have this very restrictive
de-identified data in these situations
where we can't obtain consent so
marrying the restrictive data to a new
consent process actually really
undermines the role of de-identified
I'm hearing
and he identified data
is different than limited de-identified
data so if we want to go back to limited
de-identified data we'd have to go back
and get patient consent for that because
there's a possibility of tracing a back
of a patient when you have truly
de-identified data it's truly protecting
the patient identity
is that what I'm hearing
I'm putting limited data sets aside
because that's another can of worms but
the
um
yes the the role of de-identified data
is that it cannot be linked to any
specific person and the reason for that
is because we have not obtained consent
from that person so the process because
we don't have consent the process we go
through is to completely strip the data
so that it's not identifiable
identifiable to any individual person
and then we use that information to do
our research
so to to link de-identified data to a
consent process really undermines the
role of de-identified data in the
research process the reason it exists is
because it's not a consensible situation
so
if we have consent we would use more
expansive data we would not use this
restrictive form so linking consent to
de-identify data actually becomes more
constraining right it basically makes it
impossible to use the the de-identified
data its role is when we can't obtain
consent so to add to that new
restriction on right
undermine the use of it what I'm what
I'm hearing here is there's a real
disconnect because
either you need to be able to use the
de-identified data or you know what what
we've said here all the way through is
whatever you get actual consent to is
fine so what I am hearing is for the
purpose
of what we do with this bill now
is that my suggestion is that we present
lines 1 to 14 to the committee
if if we can do so with the unanimous
recommendation and give up on the
de-identified data for another day
I think that's that would be I think we
want to come out of this with unanimous
consent on what our process is we want
to make sure that whatever we're doing
is something we all can get behind I do
think that this is important but I think
that it is
a conversation that is complex there's a
role of de-identified data as well just
to make sure that there's less of an
opportunity for for data leaks too I
understand that they're rare but they do
happen so the more that you can
constrain the data set a it's less less
to Crunch which helps I spent too much
time in SAS and my econ courses but it
also there's benefits to it and there's
also detriments I I really would like to
see us agree to lines 3 through 14 and
get this out unanimous and then keep
working on this
I concur I think it's a good compromise
because the other
way to do this would be to retain the
full bill which would then delay
everything completely right by breaking
it apart this way we can get this part
through and we can still work over the
summer to introduce another bill next
year which would be the same time
Horizon if we actually retained it so I
think it's a good compromise where we
can
have this part of it done get through
consensus get it on the dock it get it
passed and then hopefully during the
summer time heads can come together
stakeholders and talk about how to come
up with another bill
I think that that's wonderful process
and I know we all have a driving fire
behind us because of some of our late
colleagues that felt very strongly about
this topic and not just our colleague
but we have friends and family members
who've experienced these diseases too so
just because it's not included in this
bill it doesn't mean that it's not under
consideration we want to make sure that
we don't lose the the larger impact of
making sure that people can have access
to the right clinical trials now because
of the debate about the de-identified
data
um would you like to to draft the
amendment we can have the amendment
drafted one through 14. I'll draft the
amendment 1 through 14. is there
anything folks want to change out see
any I think comments any word Smith I
think as you as you drafted it there I
think we were all pretty comfortable
with it okay yes
um and and my suggestion would be to put
all three names on the on the draft and
we can present it to the committee and
I'm sorry not to get to the other part
but
I just think there are too many moving
Parts there for us to and I don't want
to hold up I think we're all agreed we
don't want to hold up the other pieces
so yes
thank you again yes thank you and thank
you for your patience with us and I hope
you'll stay in good communication so as
we work on this we can make sure that
that we're moving towards the right
direction absolutely thank you again
thank you thank you and then with that
we will have this committee Amendment
drafted in all three of our names so we
should be able to introduce that at our
next um get an executive session
scheduled and then I think we I think
we've done some good good work here will
that be on June 1st
um I I believe there was an attempt to
have a work session on the 24th are you
available on the 24th the my my
understanding from the chair is
rescheduling something for the 24th okay
I'll get it out
fantastic then we will make sure that we
have that scheduled for the 24th
fantastic thank you all I appreciate all
of your hard work and I will close the